father soon but when you have a group
like this makes it a lot easier actually
it was lower than most to me it was a
lot of money to work with under 10
million dollars in spite of a month
that's very difficult to get a baby
coming and have great actors I bargained
for from Jeffrey Maggie Joel wrong
t-bone director once these two guys came
on
it's up extreme excited well I don't
know that you can't prepare for that
really as testimony has never been any
warrants this circle and when you have
guys like t-bone and Jeffrey's in the
United chill abilities no pressure on me
am I oh I have predictions for myself
lodi maybe Manny baby just for that
think about this guy right here I'm so
nephew how do you don't bother to you
just take my transcripts raised in
detail or do you have black rain check
no we've got to look at a long
friendship you've our fourth
collaboration together three times its
actors and first time working with
directly but it won't be the last that's
one else ever salut what's that album
daughter gets a-what to try to get
around well you know when you wear an
actor in toil in obscurity for a long
time become a bridesmaid time after time
after time and your tickets didn't you
you know it takes a really strong
partner and that's what what I have
that's what I meant to say well this is
very exciting it's the first screams
like what advice do you have for you
know newbies you hit it right out of all
packed the first time two things one
don't get off and then we're to get your
screenplay to Robert Duvall next job he
could go back and finally direct a high
school play do you have any favorite is
on you prove that help you never
certainly these two producers behind a
Robin shooting of course t-bone and low
collaborating it and very marvelous is a
wonderful cinematographers just great
spirit and the guy who really knows
more
you